[موسيقى]
هذه هي الطائره الثانيه التي تصل اليوم
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه من نوع
سي 1 30 التابع للقوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه وهي قادمه من بورت سودان تحمل
على متنها قرابه السبعين شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه
ضمننا عمليات اجلاء الرعايه من السودان
الى مدينتي جده
[موسيقى]
هنا لحظه نزول الرعايه من الطائره
العسكريه التابعه للقوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه
وهم يحملون جنسيات متعدده هنا قائد قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه اللواء عبد الله
الزهراني وكذلك السفير البنجلاديشي لدى
السعوديه وكذلك عدد من القاده وايضا
البعثات الدبلوماسيه المعتمده
لدى السعوديه
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه يتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم هنا في منصات الجوازات وتقنيات
حديثه موفره من اجل سرعه انهاء الاجراءات
النقيب عبد الرحمن القثامي من مركز
الاعلامي في مديريه في المديريه العامه
للجوازات كيف يتم انهاء اجراءات الرعايه
الذين لا يحملون ثبوتات لديهم ما تزال
المدير العامه للجوازات مستمره في استقبال
الرعايه من الدول الشقيقه والصديقه
والقادمين الى المملكه من خلال رحلات
النقل الجوي وكذلك الرحلات عبر السفن
البحريه يتم التحقق من الرعايه والركاب
القادمين والذين لا يحملوا الوثائق السفر
من جنسياتهم وتحديد الجنسيات بعد ذلك يتم
التواصل مع ممثلياتهم الملحقيات بلدانهم
لاصدار وثائق سفر لهم عند صدور وثائق
السفر يتم تدوينها في انظمه الحاسب الالي
واصدار التاشيرات اللازمه لهم وتسهيل
دخولهم الى المملكه تمهيدا لمغادرتهم الى
اوطانهم اكثر من ثلاثه عشر شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه وصلوا الى جده بعد عمليات اجلال من
قبل القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه
والقوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وفرقطات
وسفن اجنبيه
كذلك تم مغادره معظمهم الى بلدانهم بعد
التنسيق مع بعثاتهم الدبلوماسيه لقناه
العربيه هاني الصفيان جده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات